في مشاركته الاولى في كاس العالم سيلعب هو
المنتخب القطري ضمن المجموعه الاولى الى
جانبه منتخباتي الاكوادور سنغال وهولندا
لا تنقصوا لاعبي قطر الخبره في المحافل
العالميه فقد توجب بلقب كاس اسيا مطلع
العام 2019 بسجل المميز بعد ان سجل 19
هدفا مقابل هدف واحد في مرمى وكان في
نهائي ضد اليابان بالاضافه لتالقي قطر في
كاس اسيا سنحت للعنابي فرصته الاحتكاك
باقوى منتخبات العالم خلال سنوات الماضيه
وذلك بمشارته كضيفين في بطوله كوبا امريكا
وكذلك الكاس الذهبيه الاتحاد
وايضا بالمشاركه في مجموعه تصفيات
الاوروبيه المؤهله الى المونديال
كله تلك التجارب اعطت مدربه الاسباني
فليكس سانشيز تصورا كافيا للتشكيله التي
سيقدمها خلال المونديال
ويبرز اكرم عفيف الذي استقل موهبته في
الملاعب الاوروبيه بخوده تجاربها في
بلجيكا اسبانيا قبل العوده الى فريقه
السده وهناك ايضا القائد حسن الهيدوس الذي
خاضها اكثر من مئه وستين مباراه مع
العنابي بالاضافه الى اهداف المنتخب بطوله
اسيا الاخيره المعز علي اليوم المنتظر
لمنتخب قطر سيكون في السابعه من مساء يوم
الاحد الموافق ل 20,000 من نوفمبر عندما
تكتب قطر اسمها ضمن قائمه منظمي المونديال
باستضافه افضل منتخبات العالم على ارضها
من خيمتها العملاقه في استاد البيت ستعلن
انطلاقه النسخه الثانيه والعشرين من بطوله
كاس العالم
ملعب البيت المستوحى تصميمه من بيت الشعر
حيث اعتاد الاجداد السكن ستستقبل قطر في
احد ضيوفها الذي وصل من امريكا الجنوبيه
منتخب الاكوادور في افتتاح كاس العالم